[Música]
con perdidas de reacción en los mercados
a la elección de gabriel boric o como
presidente de chile una de las promesas
del ex líder estudiantil y representante
de la izquierda que derrotó al
ultraderechista jose antonio kast es
acabar con el modelo neoliberal que ha
imperado en la nación por décadas
la vacuna del laboratorio estadounidense
nueva bucks recibió el aval del ente
regulador de la unión europea la ema
autorizó su aplicación de emergencia en
mayores de 18 años el laboratorio podría
empezar a distribuirla desde enero
únicamente se espera la luz verde de la
comisión europea
peng shuai se retracta la estrella del
tenis chino cuyas acusaciones desataron
preocupación por su seguridad apareció
en televisión la deportista negó haber
sido agredida sexualmente por un alto
dirigente del partido comunista después
de haberlo denunciado ella misma pero
hay quienes cuestionan su declaración
buenos días para todos y gracias por
continuar con nosotros en francés 24 mi
nombre es daniel hablando no comenzamos
en chile en donde los mercados
reaccionan con escepticismo a la
elección del izquierdista gabriel boric
o como presidente en sus primeras
operaciones de este lunes la bolsa de
santiago tuvo pérdidas de más del 5% en
su principal indicador aunque ya se ha
ido moderando mientras que sqm una de
las principales mineras del país se
desplomaba un 11% al inicio de la sesión
a las 9 de la mañana hora local el peso
chileno por su parte perdía un 3% o
resultado preparó el siguiente reporte
con los retos económicos que le esperan
al nuevo mandatario
chile es la quinta economía más grande
de latinoamérica la nueva administración
chilena debe enfrentar una inflación
histórica un descapitalizado sistema de
pensiones y los mayores índices de
desigualdad de la región la inflación es
superior al 6% el doble de la meta del
banco central chileno durante la
pandemia el producto interno bruto se
contrajo un 58 % y fue la mayor caída en
cuatro décadas la pandemia hizo que se
permitiera el retiro anticipado de los
fondos de pensiones el país se aprobó
hacerlo otras veces que representaron
unos 48.000 millones de dólares chile
que es pionero en latinoamérica en la
capitalización individual ha sido
ampliamente criticado por el manejo de
estos fondos de pensiones por las bajas
jubilaciones pero el crecimiento
económico superior al 17 por ciento es
producto de los precios del cobre y las
ayudas públicas a los hogares que brindó
el gobierno así como el efectivo que
empujó el retiro masivo de los fondos de
vejez chile el mayor productor mundial
de cobre el litio y yodo mostró un
aumento del 35 por ciento del valor de
exportaciones de cobre en noviembre las
valorizaciones de los envíos del metal
rojo representaron 4000 920 millones de
dólares pero no todas son buenas cifras
la pobreza se situó en 10 8% durante el
2020 lo que representa a 2,1 millones de
personas mientras que la pobreza extrema
alcanzó el 43 por ciento de la población
la desigualdad ha sido extrema en los
últimos 120 años incluso después del fin
de la dictadura de augusto pinochet
según world inequality lab apenas el 1%
de la población posee casi la mitad del
total de la riqueza del país la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico ocde afirma que
chile es uno de los países más
desiguales de la región tan sólo por
detrás de costa rica pero al mismo
tiempo es la nación que más quiere que
el estado reduzca su nivel de
desigualdad
y en más noticias de américa latina' en
un nuevo revés para el presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro el tribunal
supremo de londres le dio la razón a la
oposición en la disputa legal sobre
millonarias reservas de oro la máxima
instancia judicial británica
aceptó en parte del recurso presentado
por la oposición con el que pretendía
que le otorgaran el poder legal sobre
1.000 millones de dólares en lingotes
almacenada almacenados en el banco de
inglaterra este lunes se confirmó que el
gobierno británico reconoce al líder
opositor juan white o como presidente
del país y por lo tanto sería el 1
nicolás maduro quien tiene derecho a
acceder a la millonaria reserva sin
embargo será la división comercial del
tribunal superior la que determina en
última instancia a quién se le autoriza
la entrega del oro
y la agencia europea del medicamento
respaldo el uso de la vacuna
estadounidense novavax por lo que
recomendó a las autoridades autorizar su
licencia
este dictamen es un paso previo a que la
comisión europea acepte su
comercialización y convertiría a novavax
en la quinta vacuna en superar este
filtro científico europeo el inmunizador
está recomendado para adultos mayores de
18 años requiere administrarse en dos
dosis con veintiún días de diferencia y
puede ser almacenada mal vinculado y
distribuido a temperatura de
refrigerador
los resultados de los estudios muestran
una eficacia de la vacuna para novak
súbita de alrededor de 90% la cepa
original del zar co2 y algunas variantes
preocupantes como alfa y beta fueron las
más comunes que circulaban cuando los
estudios estuvieron en curso actualmente
existen datos limitados sobre la
eficacia de nueva subida frente a otras
variantes de interés incluido o micro
cambiamos de información esta vez para
hablar de israel el consejo de ministros
acordó este lunes prohibir los viajes a
eeuu canadá y otros 8 países en un
intento de frenar la variante omicron
una decisión que si es aprobada por el
parlamento entraría a regir desde la
medianoche del miércoles y sumaría a
estas naciones a francia y reino unido-
que ya tienen esa prohibición el primer
ministro naftalí bennett dijo que había
comenzado una quinta ola por la variante
y que su gobierno seguiría restringiendo
los viajes para evitar más cierres
y los países de occidente expresaron su
preocupación por los resultados de las
elecciones legislativas del domingo en
hong kong en las que arrasaron los
candidatos pro beijing esto se produce
en medio de la participación más baja
desde el traspaso de la región a china
en 1997 a continuación un informe
[Aplausos]
victoria garantizada eso es lo que
cantan en el escenario el candidato pro
beijing carl ichán y sus partidarios
mientras se preparan para celebrar una
rotunda victoria electoral
chan y otros candidatos pro beijing
dominaron las elecciones legislativas de
hong kong superando a los moderados e
independientes
creo que es una noticia falsa llamarla
elecciones falsas porque son elecciones
reales y nos han elegido los votantes
creo que debemos respetar las elecciones
de los electores esto es la democracia a
pesar de estas afirmaciones solo voto el
30 por ciento del padrón electoral
registrado la participación más baja
desde la entrega de la ciudad china de
no votamos porque no va a suponer
ninguna diferencia es una elección de
círculo pequeño las elecciones fueron
las primeras que se celebraron desde que
beijing reformó el sistema electoral de
hong kong a principios de este año las
reformas permitieron a beijing
investigar a todos los candidatos y
limitar drásticamente el número de
escaños elegidos directamente en el
consejo legislativo cuatro millones y
medio de residentes tenían derecho a
votar pero sus papeletas sólo decidieron
escaños de 90 el resto fueron elegidos
directamente por comités pro beijing y
sectores profesionales y empresariales
como el financiero y el de construcción
y la estrella del tenis chino peng shuai
negó haber sido agredida sexualmente por
un alto dirigente del partido comunista
y declaró que vive libremente los
comentarios los hizo en su primera
entrevista desde que sus acusaciones
desataron la preocupación por su
seguridad sin embargo las declaraciones
no aliviaron la preocupación de la
asociación de tenis femenino
ben swift fue entrevistada en un acto
promocional en shanghai para los juegos
olímpicos de invierno de pekín apareció
junto a la ex estrella de la nba yao
ming cuando un periodista de singapur le
pregunto ella negó haber sido agredida
sexualmente
ante todo debo subrayar que nunca he
dicho ni escrito nada acusando a nadie
de haberme agredido sexualmente ese es
un punto muy importante eso contradice
su denuncia del 2 de noviembre las redes
sociales de que el ex vice primer
ministro chino zhang a oli le había
obligado a mantener relaciones sexuales
en varias ocasiones tras esta acusación
la ex campeona de dobles de wimbledon y
el abierto de francia desapareció de la
vida pública hasta esta sesión de firma
de autógrafos el 21 de noviembre lo que
pone en duda su libertad de movimiento y
su seguridad la preocupación se extendió
por todo el mundo incluyendo la onu la
casa blanca y otras estrellas del tenis
mo la asociación femenina de la
disciplina reaccionó el domingo a su
declaración seguimos pidiendo una
investigación completa justa y
transparente sin censura sobre su
acusación de agresión y la asociación de
tenis femenino ha suspendido todos los
torneos en china incluida hong kong ante
la preocupación por payne el hecho
alimentó las peticiones de boicot a los
juegos de pekín el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores chino ha dicho que el caso se
exageró maliciosamente
hasta aquí es informativo ustedes
gracias por su sintonía recuerde que
pueden seguir viendo nuestra
programación en france 24 y en france 24
punto com feliz día
[Música]